the following is something Conan wanted
to do he will make more whenever time
and fate allow he apologizes to Charlie
Rose for stealing his set hey there I'm
Conan O'Brien welcome to serious
jibber-jabber
I'm here with Pulitzer Prize winning
author edmund morris he spent over 30
years writing three books about the life
of Theodore Roosevelt as well as the
biography of Ronald Reagan Dutch Edmund
thanks a lot for joining us you know one
of the reasons I wanted to do this
particularly with you is because I had
you on the late-night program I think we
had all of seven minutes to talk you
left and I thought I want to talk to
that man for a long time probably longer
than you want to talk to me so I was
very happy that you could be here well
as I recall I had one minute and you had
five so yes well today I'm also gonna
dominate the conversation that's what I
do you don't know much about me I've
been a lifelong presidential history
buff always been fascinated American
presidents but Teddy Roosevelt eluded me
until your book started to come out and
I was introduced to him so maybe you
could tell me why did you choose Teddy
Roosevelt what grabbed you about TR he
eluded me to in a way because I became
conscious of him aware of him was when I
was a boy of about ten living in Kenya
Nairobi Kenya and I for some reason was
looking through a history book about the
city which was only 50 years old and
there was a photograph of this famous
former American president who'd come to
Kenya on a major safari in 1910 and he
wore a pith helmet and he had these big
teeth and a mustache and something about
the face of Theodore Roosevelt appealed
to me as a boy and I just thought he
would be it would be fun to be with him
yeah there was something about about
that image for 25 years really because
he's he's I think I'm
had this thought before that the great
presidents are easily caricatured you
know that they they look there's
something about them that's easy to
capture and Teddy Roosevelt probably one
of the most famous caricatures that we
ever had in us is a letter to him you
would just draw some teeth and
spectacles on an envelope but the post
office would deliver it were they really
I get that people just draw hair and it
shows up this is one of the things that
brought him back to me and and it
happened around the time that your first
book came out living on the Upper West
Side I used to pass the Natural History
Museum all the time and it passed the
statute the statue and it says at the
base of the statue I remembered stopping
and looking at this author statesman
scholar humanitarian historian Patriot
ranch man conservationist Explorer
naturalist scientist and soldier I
remember having a thought that can't be
possible he could not have done all
those things and he did could we have a
president like that again I think not my
wife always says his secret was servants
but nevertheless to pack all that in
into sixty years plus be President
United States for almost eight of them
it's phenomenal and his secret insofar
as it could be explained was simply that
he moved and thought so fast he read so
fast he read three pages a minute
photographing each page as he read his
desk was clear of all his work by
lunchtime when he was president he just
was a very fast person he also I mean
keep in mind he's reading in different
languages - mm-hmm how many he read in
Italian he couldn't speak Italian but he
read French and German fluently and
spoke them pretty damn well
and of course English and you know
what's incredible him is okay you
brought up he's moving fast this is the
impression I had when I read your three
volumes I sensed it a little bit in the
first two when I get to the later stage
of his life it was a greater impression
that I had is that today we'd call him
manic you'd almost want
you read about him and you think this is
a man that almost probably today's
someone would medicate him because there
seems to be there's a there's a rush to
action that at times feels almost
Worrell and psychotic is that is that
but we're in the presence of a person
like that who is manic one tends to
become very edgy and there's no
testimony by anybody that being with him
was enervating he there was a sort of
calm about him oddly enough even though
he was such a bundle of energy when he
listened to you when you were talking to
him for example he was cat elliptically
still concentrated enormously and his
sentences when he wrote were carefully
thought-out and composed there was no
there was no undue rush about him no
hysteria he was a con man who just
happened to work to think and move five
times as fast as normal human beings
would you I think you've said this
before that you're not sure that you'd
enjoy a conversation with Teddy
Roosevelt or look forward to a
conversation whatever is that true as a
conversationalist do you think he'd be
an easy person to talk to no like all
presidents he was overbearingly
concerned with dominating the
conversation so if you've spent the
evening with him you would just have to
accept the fact that he was going to
talk and talk and talk and talk and use
this first-person pronoun which he loved
so much
eyyy eyyy I me but he was fortunately
unlike many overbearing presidents a
charming man and his stories were so
funny and his perceptions were so acute
that it was a treat to listen to him now
we talked about this a little off-camera
but I wanted to bring it up here I love
to go to historical presidential sites I
love to visit presidential homes and I
think one of the best easily might be
TRS home in Oyster Bay and I was struck
by the fact as you described it in your
book that he saw this property when he
was younger and just said I'd like to
have that and he fortunately had the
resources to do it but then he
constructs it's still a very young age
this
massive home as if he knew that he had
to build himself a giant house it's like
an act of will to build a house like
that
you know 22 rooms just off he got
married to his young wife straight out
of Harvard he am as you say he just knew
that he was going to amount to something
enormous it was apparent even long
before that and his letters his teenage
letters to his sisters for example
whenever he got onto some public subject
and in the letter he knew posterity
would be reading this letter and he
would sign the letter Theodore Roosevelt
to his sisters well I normally would
call himself the--or teddy
but those posterity letters he was
writing even in his teens so he's
writing with the now he's writing with
the idea that his this is gonna be
important for history even when he's a
teenager when I was researching his
first honeymoon he married this gorgeous
Boston girl Alice Hathaway Lea mm-hmm he
kept a personal diary in those days at
Harvard documenting every day of their
relationship so naturally I was very
interested to know what was gonna be
like when he finally married Alice and
took her to Springfield and got into bed
with her you sound very creepy by the
way talking exactly biographers a weird
people okay to accept this so yeah so
you're exploring his sex less so I was
hoping to you know what it was like in
bed without honestly and I turn the page
of the diary he says our sacred
happiness our happiness is too sacred to
be written about that was it and I got
the distinct feeling reading this that
he in 1882 was talking to me mister
future biographer right this is private
stay out of this one night right so he
was conscious even then but one day some
beady-eyed historian was going to be
going through his books talking to a
beady-eyed talk-show host about it in a
dark room like two creeps he so he knows
that you you had said before we started
taping that it's Jeffersonian to
Jefferson has to build himself a big
house on a hill there's a certain
there's a similarity there in these men
that seem to think I need this I need
this almost this is the I need a box
this big to contain my great personality
true Washington to George Washington's
Mount Vernon I don't know what it is but
that Lyndon Johnson is his ranch is very
much a I think a little don't you think
a little bit of a statement of it is
it's like very much he was important for
him to have statesmen come and see him
at the ranch people needed to come to
his ranch it's you get a sense of his
personality when you go there yeah
Ronald Reagan in contrast was not like
that mm-hmm
he was a very strange combination of of
an enormous kid he knew his identity he
knew his purpose he knew what he wanted
out of his life what he wanted to
achieve with the United States but he
had no personal ego at it but no ego he
had no desire to live in splendid
premises to impress people he wasn't
particularly interested in credit for
what he did his idea of paradise was
this dinky little Ron Chopin named
mountains above Santa Barbara which the
most squalid little shack you ever saw
it's not impressive at all no he put it
together himself it's got pictures
hanging crooked on the wall in a yellow
shag rub covering the toilet seat and
dead flies hang from the flypaper at the
table outside and he thought it was
paradise you know it's funny because you
get the impression of that talking about
Reagan that contrast to me contrasting
him with Theodore Roosevelt Fira
Roosevelt is very outgoing Reagan I
think a lot of people who think of him
that way but he was not in in that sense
really outgoing was he no he was a very
aloof person in private in fact in
private he was not really there one just
had the feeling that he was needing to
get back onto some
stage and perform and as soon as he did
he became magical and big and
authoritative but in private Regan was
dull Hollow
did you ever have in I can't say if it's
hundreds of hours but in all the amount
of time that you spent with President
Reagan was there ever a moment that you
had with him a private moment that told
you a lot about him that really
Illustrated something about him that
would help the rest of us key into him
as a person well once in the Oval Office
I asked him about his youth in Des
Moines when he was a young sportscaster
and again I was thinking about 6 I was I
said to him um mr. president what sort
of things do you do at night when you a
young man in Des Moines I was happy he's
gonna tell me about his girlfriends I
knew he had a gorgeous girlfriend from
Drake University he said oh I used to go
to the advertising Club I said really
why he said well we had the best
speakers from out of town they all came
to the advertising time and I learned a
lot about public speaking listening to
those men he said I remember one guy who
came and he was that we thought he was
the president of a toilet paper
manufacturing company and he gave this
speech about the manufacture of toilet
paper and we were laughing fit to bust
oh it was so funny
so I said um so he was a comedian was he
he said oh yes it was a put-on job but I
can remember that speech to this day
says the President of the United States
in the erekle office so I said well can
you remember any of it now and at which
his eyes went opaque his voice changed
and for the next eight minutes he
disgorged the speech in a voice that was
not ronald reagan's voice he was
possessed by the memory of this man that
he heard turning this endless not very
funny anecdote in 1933 and he knows it
word for word
it came up it was like a recording
mechanism
and when he finally was through I said
mr. president did you do to give you the
scrip did you memorize this from the
scrip he said no I haven't thought about
it until today and where's that tell you
well it told me that he was some by
Nature thespian he was a recording
mechanism he was not a great actor as we
all know watching his movies but he was
a great actor as president and his
nature was to perform to learn to
articulate words that were put into him
it was really creepy moment but the same
time revelatory you know what's
interesting is that you know because
we're talking about these two presidents
and their similarities and their
differences but you know Theodore
Roosevelt before he was president people
feared if this guy becomes president
because he had this kind of bellicose
warlike image we're gonna all be in
trouble he could be dangerous people
thought of him as this could be a
dangerous person the same thing I
remembered when I was a teenager and
Ronald Reagan's running for the
Presidency and a lot of people are
talking about we can't have this guy's
finger on the button this is gonna be a
real problem he's you know he's it's
dangerous there was this both both
statesmen when they become president are
actually quite diplomatic they're
sparing in their use of force and
they're they're not afraid to use
diplomacy and they're quite
sophisticated about it we've seen which
seem like actually kind of a shocking
surprise to a lot of people what is the
effect of the office the office does
change a man they suddenly become aware
of the fact that they are have to be
statesmen that they represent the United
States and in TRS case his natural
bellicosity smoothed out he became
diplomatic and thoughtful and civilized
in Reagan's case he again became his
religious faith came out very strong
even he began to realize that a man in
and control of the country's nuclear
policy has to have moral considerations
weighing upon him all the time so he too
became statesman like and charitably
inclined it's it's the effect of great
power so the office chambers critic
right well the office changes them then
you also get the sense and this is
really true with Teddy Roosevelt he
gives up the office it's one of the
strangest things very hard to understand
but in 1908 he can run again and he
doesn't he
he pretty much hands the office over to
someone who secretly he probably
believes is not up to the office is not
of his stature mmm Taft and he hands the
office over and their friends and very
quickly you can tell it eats away at him
and he regrets it and you almost feel
like that someone who once he had the
presidency he couldn't handle get a very
difficult time not being president yes I
thought it was a statesman like act to
give up the presidency when he could
have had a third term or for that matter
of fourth right in those days on a
plateau but he felt that almost eight
years in power enough and he felt that
power should be given back to the people
so it was a statesman like act took to
give it up but as you say once he gave
it up since his nature was to be
presidential he kind of regretted the
power that he'd lost and wanted it back
not immediately he did think the
President Taft his hand-picked successor
would carry on his policies particularly
his conservation policies and it was
only when he came back from his marathon
year-long safari in Africa in 1910 that
he realized that to President Taft was
perverting his record and that's when he
began to hanker to get the White House
back what's interesting to me is when he
wants the White House back and
eventually decides to run against Taft
it is nasty you know people love to talk
about how the rhetoric in the United
States today it's sunk to a new low and
they forget that we've we've been here
before but Teddy Roosevelt fighting
for the nomination eventually making his
own party
it is a it it's brutal isn't it yes I
think that campaigning transforms a man
just as becoming president transforms a
man in this case once a man is
campaigning he becomes the visceral
animal aggression begins to become a
large part of it mm-hmm and even
although TR and Taft were sweetly
dispersed to each other when TR was
president the fact that they were
fighting each other for the presidency
in 1912 made the fight vicious even Taft
was the most gentle benign person became
shrewish and unpleasantly aggressive
it's the it's the I suppose the
adrenaline of campaigning I remember
interviewing Jimmy Carter after he left
the presidency in fact he was asking me
and a few other historians for advice as
to how to write his memoirs as he
pronounced it and I said mister he said
I said mr. president you know what I
think you could do to begin them is have
a prologue describing that magical day
when you became president and you and
Rosalyn Carter your wife got out of the
limo coming down from Capitol Hill the
Sun was shining and after all the
claustrophobia and the insecurity of the
Nixon years the four years here was the
president in new president the United
States walking long hand-in-hand with
his wife in the bright sunshine I said
that was a great moment and if you made
a prologue describing that moment and
then you could write the rest of the
book was the story of how you got to
that time and he said no I'm gonna start
with the night I triumphed over scoop
Jackson in the Florida primary yeah he's
eyes flashed and I realized that was the
most cathartic moment in his life the
Florida primary when he shafted scooped
Johnson the Jackson and became
the likely next president well you know
it's hard to imagine any modern
president or probably any president in
history who doesn't have that you have
to have that killer instinct and the
disconnect a little bit as we tend to
elevate these people we put them on
Mount Rushmore we build monuments to
them a good politician needs to be as
you said it's a political animal has to
be vicious and so you know the the
Federalists that's incredibly nasty
stuff you know Aaron Aaron Burr and
Alexander Hamilton I mean people people
think that that politics in America got
nastier and I always think I don't know
that it did it's become the tools are
different now
but you read some of those broad sides
from the 1790 to the early 19th century
our civil war I mean it's always been
vicious it's incredibly vicious try grin
of losing too is acute the the sting of
the presidential defeat even if you're
some designer ambitious as Gerald Ford
mm-hmm
when he was beaten for a reelection he
couldn't get over it for years yeah I
remember Carter saying to me that
although he recovered from defeat he
said Rosalynn will never be the same
really so she's in it in a way of you
get this a little bit in the same sense
with the first President George Bush
that his loss to Clinton that's right
that's another example I was a
documentary recently it's very very
reverential towards George Bush and
there is one sour note that I saw in the
entire documentary which is when they
asked him about Ross Perot and he you
know he's been so charming and so nice
and so even-handed about anything I
asked my mom for up Ross Perot said I'm
not gonna talk about him he cost me the
election I don't like him I'm not gonna
talk about him yeah and everything else
had been I love being up in Maine life
is good
sunny buh-bum this hidden aggression
comes out yeah and you say losing that
losing that office is something that
people have been challenged for it to
that's that they can never forgive
either Reagan was the sweetest man he
could he found it very difficult to say
or for that matter think anything
negative about everybody about anybody
but he was strangely savage whenever he
talked about his predecessors really I
didn't know that yeah he said of Jimmy
Carter he said you know that man he was
the only guy who ever came into the
White House and left at a smaller man
and when he came in and he was
contemptuous of Jerry Ford he said he
wasn't elected to anything he was not
legitimate and I said what about LBJ he
said do you know that LBJ used to say
after he left the White House that there
never was a night that he went to sleep
without worrying that World War three
would begin while he was asleep as in
how can a president have that sort of
moral cowardice and fear the arts at the
start of a war when he's in office so he
was oddly vituperative toward his
predecessors particularly those who'd
run against makes me think of an actor
thinking about the person who played the
role before them and being contemptuous
a really good actor Sir Laurence Olivier
is not interested in watching someone
else's Hamlet and and so that's to me it
says a lot about the actor Ronald Reagan
yes this is the part this is my part
this is the part I play and it can't be
played any other way of the three books
that you wrote on Teddy Roosevelt
it's the third that obviously there's a
lot of melancholy in the third in my
opinion because he's struggling so much
to figure out to find his place and he
wants to run again and I think the
saddest chapter and in in his life at
that point is the loss of his son he
loses his son in World War one and I'd
imagine there must be a an incredible
amount of guilt it's not something
people didn't go to
he'd never have gone to a therapist or
psychiatrist it was no such thing as
being introspective that way but he
loses his son in a war that he
championed that he and he very much
wanted to fight in that war Teddy
Roosevelt but wasn't allowed to he
encourages all his sons to go off and
his son Quentin is killed how did it can
you
was there guilt there do you think yes I
think so
Quentin of course was the youngest and
the brightest of the children the one
most like himself he was in fact it
illegally young to have gone off to war
but of course he had to be the one who
was killed and his death in July of 1918
hit TR with such cosmic force that he
never recovered from it at once for the
first time in his life he realized what
war really was he'd romanticized it so
much after that up to that point ever
since he was a boy himself he'd imagined
that war was glorious and romantic and
his own experience of war on the
spanish-american war when he charged up
San Juan Hill had been ecstatic but he
didn't realize that war by then had
become mechanized and brutal and fascism
was incipient in the German campaign and
when this machine this war machine shot
down his only son his youngest son who's
a pilot it was a pilot and he saw that
photograph that I reproduced in the book
was dead boy lying by the brook the
Germans took a photograph of him laid
him out and put him next to the wreckage
of the plane took a photo he look like a
steer fallen off a hook I think the
impact of that was so great that TR
never recovered psychologically and in
fact he died just six months later a few
months later he dies yeah and it's
fashionable now for people to
psychoanalyze and it's hard not to in
the world we live in today but you think
sometimes that we've learned so much now
about not acknowledging guilt not
acknowledging certain emotions and how
that can be how that can prey upon you
and you think about someone like Teddy
Roosevelt who out lives
his father you know died at a young age
and his loses his wife and loses his
first daughter and then loses his son
that there might be a lot of
unacknowledged feelings there and when
someone's just not introspective and
pushing forward that might have an
effect on them guilt probably that he
didn't fully understand himself he was
of that Victorian ilk that believed that
strong emotion should be suppressed for
example that beautiful young wife I was
talking about earlier on Alice nee died
after only four years of marriage died
having just given birth to their
daughter Alice and in the same house on
the same night TR his mother died so
these two women died on him I almost -
Mateus Lee the shock of Alice's death
was so great upon him that for the rest
of his life he never mentioned her name
he didn't even talk about her to his to
their child Alice he refused to even
mention her in his autobiography it was
like he just wanted to suppress
eradicate expunge the memory that was a
very Victorian thing and what is he
saying in the diary that he keeps that
day he's right this sentence it's not
coming to mind right now you'll know it
but he has a line that he writes in his
diary the day that he was is his wife
and his daughter the light has gone out
of my life yeah and you wrote a big
cross so if you suppress grief that in
so extreme of fashion it's obviously
going to create suppressed and
unhappiness and trauma later on in life
which I think explains why he was so
melancholy in his last years and what
about Regan again a famously difficult
person to psychoanalyze but the child of
an alcoholic and maybe not an accident
that he became very adept at you know if
you saw these painful things and he was
a child he became it's a it's a classic
transformation to make yourself somebody
who can name other people the strange
thing about Regan was when he was a
young star in Hollywood he hung out with
um happy Bogart and Pat O'Brien and all
these boo
the Stars and he would go out drinking
with them he would nurse a beer right
through the night and they would be
drinking Spencer Tracy was another
they'd be drinking to the point of
vomiting and he would take them home and
put them to bed so alcohol had no
terrors for him he could live with it
I'd like the children and many
alcoholics his suppressions were were
more primary for example he had a child
that he never talked about who was born
to his wife Jane Wyman in 1948 the worst
year of his life and this child was born
she had Elaine Christine and she died
after only about 24 hours of life he
could not bring himself ever to
acknowledge their existence even when I
tried to talk to him about it when his
what when his mother and when you ask
him what he he just
he'd say I don't want to discuss it or
he would say absolutely nothing and he
would just he was a past master at
changing the subject
he would've and he would just get out of
it slip out of it and of course it was
very difficult for me to touch on things
like that with him you know one of the
unpleasant aspects of biographies that
you do if your subject is still alive
have to deal with primary things that
often it's so painful for them that one
shrinks from doing it and his first
marriage not working out was he would
never talk about that marriage because
Jane divorced him because she found him
boring and it was also the nadir of his
career wasn't it yeah his career was
collapsing at the same time but to be to
be an actor to be a thespian to be told
by your wife that you're boring is it's
like a spear into the stomach I know
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah very good this relates to Teddy
Roosevelt had he lived and run in 1920 a
lot of people think that it would have
walked away he'd have won easily do you
believe that it's more or less certain
that he would have because there was a
Republican landslide
that year Warren Harding was enacted and
TR was the favorite for the nomination
if he hadn't died he would have been the
nominee there's no question about it at
all and he would have been elected you
probably can't even calculate how many
things that changes if Teddy Roosevelt
is president again in 1920 and not
Warren Harding who is a huge
disappointment except I think that
leaders die when they have to die they
usually die at the appropriate moment he
died when he should have the ward come
to an end
he'd suffered this tragedy and the
values that he stood for the gentlemanly
values of the 19th century had become
per se overnight so he would have had to
deal with the Jazz Age right and the age
of relativity and and galloping science
and eugenics and all these things and I
don't think with his sensibility he
could have handled now he couldn't be an
anachronism you didn't want to be in it
no one does but but he can't exist that
way why did he hate Woodrow Wilson so
much Woodrow Wilson's a progressive
Woodrow Wilson interested in enacting a
lot of the same things that the Teddy
Roosevelt Center said why did he despise
him so much not at first he liked Wilson
when he was president as he liked
everybody but and in fact up until 1911
he still got on pretty well with Wilson
whenever they met Wilson was more cagey
Wilson was not too pleased with but when
they campaigned against each other in
1912 and again the adrenaline of
campaigning turned it into a fight and
Wilson was a superb cool campaigner he
knew exactly what kind of rhetoric to
use to get to you're crazy with
resentment and the fact that he won of
course was was was sort into ours wounds
and the fact that he was president when
the war broke out in 1914 and Theodore
Roosevelt was not this parochial
presbyterian
[Music]
intellectual was in the white house a
man very little foreign knowledge very
little understanding of diplomacy and
foreign cultures it just drove TR crazy
because he knew that he should be in
there handling these matters himself and
Woodrow Wilson's working hard
what says I'm gonna keep a side of this
war and that's that first was a pacifist
yes saying and we had no place in this
war and Americans want to be kept out of
it
I always think although I hesitate to
speculate about what would have happened
that kind of thinking is usually
specious but it's it is a fact the
Theodore Roosevelt in 1914 if he had
been president when the war broke out
was a man of proven diplomatic
virtuosity he had the Nobel Peace Prize
for settling the russo-japanese war 1906
he had this enormous circle of of
European acquaintances he knew all those
emperors he knew them personally he'd
stayed in their palaces he corresponded
with him he spoke their languages he
understood their culture he was a gifted
diplomat and the only president who's
ever been called upon to mediate a
foreign war so in 1914 if he'd been in
the White House he would have been
superbly equipped to find to mediate a
settlement amongst those warring powers
it is quite apparent by early 1915 that
all the imperial powers at war with one
another did wander way out and then of
tear I had been there he probably would
have been able to bring the war to much
it was just about saving face yeah they
they all knew pretty quickly after the
sleep and plan doesn't work they know
this is Tarek this is awful where this
trench warfare is horrible and then
you're committed to it for and for a
long time so yeah that's amazing
Roosevelt is a Republican he's one of
the most famous of the Republicans but
you look at the Republican Party today
and you look at Teddy Roosevelt and you
see
he's a trust buster he's he's really
almost fanatically interested in in
reigning in business how does that fit
today with the Republican Party not at
all I think he'd be a big gun food
Democrat if he was alive now do you
think they're Republicans that are
hesitant to you know pose with statues
of Teddy Roosevelt for that reason or
not do they do they recognize the
disconnect between what his
republicanism was like versus theirs
well of course most some don't know
anything about him right in the kind of
people we have running for office these
days have no historical memory and very
little culture so Republicans tend to
identify with TR and for that matter
with Ronald Reagan simply because they
know that these men were Republicans and
were fabulously successful in their time
that's all they know right they really
studied the intricacies of TRS social
attitudes they wouldn't want to identify
with him at all
do you think of Teddy Roosevelt as a
racially progressive president for his
time he was relatively enlightened he
was a patronizing upper-class wasp
gentleman but he did sincerely believe
and within a few weeks of becoming
president proved that that he admired
any black man who could make it in
Whitey's world which is why he gave that
famous dinner to Booker T Washington in
October of 1901 ago I will sort to come
to a lot of criticism first time a black
man had ever sat down with the president
United States in the White House with
his wife and daughter around the same
table and the the explosion of racial
paranoia in the south amongst the white
Democratic South was was quite
phenomenal
and although TR felt he'd made a moral
point saying it felt entirely natural
for me to be having dinner with dr.
Washington he never invited him back
right right you know there's a lot of I
mean throughout history even
John F Kennedy is walking a line in his
presidency on civil rights you know he's
very aware that he narrowly very
narrowly won it was the closest election
up to that point and so he's pragmatic
we're talking about pragmatic people and
they have sure immoral conscience but
they're also pragmatists and their of
their time yeah by modern terms TR would
would routinely be described as a
patronizing racist as everybody if his
class was in those days but in terms of
his own time he was comparatively
enlightened President Taft for example
made a declaration as soon as he became
presently I will have no black
officeholders and Woodrow Wilson was
worse than any of them rhymes and cotton
art Southern racist TR was quite happy
to have black men at his table and come
and spend the night in his house and
that they had to be educated gentlemanly
self proved proven self developed
individuals for the general mass of
black Americans he had very little
compassion Americans seemed to like or
were very comfortable with often with
presidents that have that come from
affluence especially in times of stress
and I'm thinking about you contrast FDR
with Herbert Hoover Herbert Hoover's
completely self-made he really is
probably the icon of what should be the
hero for the depression but people are
more comfortable with Franklin Roosevelt
who of course grew up absurdly wealthy
you look at Nixon completely self-made
and comes from a poor family and has to
make it all on his own which might fuel
his paranoia as opposed to Kennedy who
you know is quite wealthy extremely
wealthy and seems more comfortable is
that it is is there anything to that
father you said it I've not thought of
that before but you're right however
that it does seem that it is a prejudice
against great wealth now yeah I mean
Romney is
routinely despised because he's so
wealthy and perhaps it's because
presidential candidates these days have
to pretend that they're not wealthy to
have to pretend that money doesn't
matter to them where whereas actually it
matters more than ever
leat the lead article the New York Times
about ten days ago was the fact that
President Obama has raised more money in
the last month and George Romney has
Mitt Romney it's all become a matter of
money
and I guess we as Americans admire and
revere money but we've gotten to the
point we don't like rich men to run for
office in the past it was not a problem
I think Americans perhaps felt that
money made candidates inherited money
made them objective and unprejudiced and
patrician and and well-bred well even
you know Lincoln's are very successful I
mean today we think of him as a
corporate lawyer mm-hmm you know he's
very successful and he obviously came
from great poverty but he had he had
amassed had not a fortune but he had
made a very good life for himself and
today that was something they didn't
give people a hard time for that
throughout a lot of them
JFK got some flack for it but not not
nearly what happens today
well JFK had the way of joking about it
he had that delicious humor presidential
candidates these days are so solemn and
serious and afraid of self-deprecating
wit yeah Romney would only joke about
his money and just toss the whole thing
like a rich guys yeah no that's fine JFK
routinely made jokes about his father
running things or his his wealth and I
think now anything it's a sound bite
culture if you can take a sound bite
even if it's self-deprecating we're
starting to I think steam the irony out
of
American political life you can't have
any yeah and it's more fun when you can
I think the last thing I just wanted to
mention was the biggest disconnect with
me and I think for a lot of probably
young people today and Teddy Roosevelt
is most pictures they see of him he's
standing over a dead rare animal and
what is it the man obviously was a
naturalist and is responsible for really
beginning the conservation movement the
United States and didn't he see the the
irony of of killing so many animals or
was it just the time and they didn't
think of it they thought there's an
inexhaustible supply of white rhinos it
was the time it was the culture Wellborn
gentleman killed large animals on both
sides of the atlantic and in fact those
from the other side of the atlantic were
a lot worse than americans were these
meow British aristocrats used to come
over here and slaughter thousands at a
time TR sat down to dinner with the
Emperor of Austria in 1910 and this is
all true a safari in which he'd
collected something like 267 specimens
in Africa but the Emperor said to him I
have killed 50,000 animals in my life so
comparatively speaking he was he was not
all that bloodthirsty and he did shoot
many many of his expeditions were
scientific and he was a passionate he's
shipping things after the Smithsonian
yeah they still have crates the
Smithsonian full of specimens they
haven't yet opened on that Safari in
1910 and it on a more profound level he
loved animals so much and his curiosity
about them
curiosity being a large part of love was
so intense right from childhood but to
kill them was the fall of ultimate
knowledge and that's why he became so
strangely possessed whenever he did kill
a large animal he would
scream and jump and singing and become
almost primeval company's reactions he
had gained knowledge of the Great Beast
right it's almost it sounds like almost
like a Native American spiritual
tradition the Beast is becoming part of
me it's funny I've been to Hyde Park and
you see this incredible collection of
Franklin Roosevelt's birds that he he
was interested in birds and he collected
them when he was young and you're
looking at them and you realize he's
nothing he killed them all
mmm which is a very street you know
birders today my father loves watching
Birds the idea that you'd kill one to
look at it you know it's very odd stuff
stuff it and put it up on the wall we
have a web question if that's okay
this is from Margie from Facebook why
didn't Teddy Roosevelt run for
re-election as a Democrat instead of
taking the third-party route which was
so destructive or he wouldn't have
dreamed of it he thought of himself as a
career Republican the Republican Party
we must remember in those days was the
party of the black man mmm-hmm he once
said addressing a black audience he said
I am pleased to address any black
audience because I know that I'm
dressing an audience of Republicans and
the Democratic Party in contrast was
strictly racist so it was inconceivable
that TR at any point in his life could
have become a Democrat so the bull moose
party the third party was really his
only alternative at that point hmm the
Progressive Party arm he wanted you felt
it represented the liberal wing of the
Republican Party in that is the way he
felt the public the party should go
alright well I think I've exhausted most
of my questions I hope I haven't wasted
your time you've exhausted me yeah this
was fantastic this is actually this is
my dream job is to is to sit and get to
talk to people like you I've loved I've
absolutely loved to loved your work what
are you working on now Thomas Edison
really no more presidents but Edison
fascinates the hell out of me why
wouldn't it would
Edison well it's his imaginative side
oddly enough he was a man of science who
invented patented 1092 inventions but
all these inventions came out of
imagination out of inspiration he was
and that's the mystery that appeals to
me how is it the technical things can
come out of an almost poetic imagination
are you liking him as you study him more
and more mm-hmm I never fall in love
with my subjects but they have to
interest me obsessively which this guy
does when when when can I read that book
I think it'll take another two or three
years before I'm through can I come by
the house check over the notes I know
where you live I know that area of
Connecticut yeah I'll come by okay do
you really have you have do you have
recording of his voice oh yes yes yes
yes those cylinders are amazingly vivid
yeah if you are if you if you unspool
them now there that the sound quality is
astonishingly vivid
mary had a little lamb that's what he
recorded on his first sermon beyond the
irony there is that he was a death that
I wrote right through his life I seem to
specialize in deaf guys they'd Beethoven
Ronald Reagan Edison uh-huh keep going I
cannot thank you enough for doing this
this is an incredible pleasure thanks
for making good yeah thanks very much
that's it for jibber-jabber my thanks to
Evan Morris for this absolute treat for
me and we'll see you next time